speaking of compromise and war let me
ask you about one last one which may be
in the future
china and the united states yeah
how do we avoid an all-out hot war with
this other superpower
in the next decade 50 years a hundred
years because
sometimes when it's quiet at night i can
hear in the long distance the drums of
war beating yeah
you know in the second part of the book
i talk about what i think have been like
these persistent like paths to peace and
one of them is increasing
interdependence and into relationships
and another one is
more checks and balances on power
i think there's more but those are
things two that are really fundamental
here because i think those two things
reduce incentives for war in two ways
one is like right now remember when we
were talking about this really simple
strategic game where
i whether in russia and ukraine or or
whatever any two rivals
i want more of the pie than you get and
and and uh the costs of word are
deterrents
but only the costs of war that i feel
right i don't care i do not care about
the costs of war to your side my rivals
i'm not even thinking of that that's
just worth zero to me i just don't care
in that simple game now in reality
uh
many groups do care about the well-being
of the other group at least a little bit
right we're in some sense to the degree
we first of all if our interests are
intertwined like our economies are
intertwined
um
that
that's not a sure-fire
way for peace and we shouldn't get
complacent because we have a globally
integrated world but that's going to be
a disincentive and if we're socially
entwined because we have great social
relationships and linkages and family or
intermarriage or whatever this is all
these things will
will will will help and then if we're
ideologically intertwined maybe we share
a
notions of liberty or maybe we just
share a common notion of humanity so i
think the fact that we're more
integrated than we've ever been on all
three fronts in the world but with china
is
is providing some insulation which is
good so i would be more worried if we
started to shed some of that insulation
which i think has been happening a
little bit
u.s economic nationalism
whatever could be the fallout of these
sanctions or a closer chinese alliance
with russia all those things could
happen those would make me more worried
because i think we've got a lot of
cushion that comes from all of this
economic social cultural interdependence
that's a social one with the internet is
a big one so basically make friends with
the people from different nations yeah
fall in love
or you don't have to fall in love you
can just have lots of sex with people
from nature but also fall in love the
thing that also should comforts me about
china is that they
china's not as centralized or as
personalized regime as russia for
example and neither one of them is as
centralized as personalized as like a as
some tin pot like purely personalized
dictatorship like you get in in some
countries the fact that china
the power is much more widely shared
is a big installation i think against
this war it will future war
um
the
the attempts by xi jinping to
personalize power over time and to make
china a more centralized and personal
ruled place which
is he's successfully moved in that
direction also worries me so anything
anything that moves china in the other
direction not necessarily being
democratic but just like a wider and
wider group of people holding power like
all of the business leaders and all the
things that have been happening the last
few centuries have actually like widened
power but anything that's moving in the
other direction does worry me because
it's going to accentuate all these five
risks i am worried about a little bit of
the demonization so yeah one of the
things
i
see with china as a problem for
americans
for maybe i'm projecting maybe it's just
my own problem but you know there seems
to be a bigger cultural gap than there
is with other superpowers throughout
history where
it's like it's almost like this own
world happening in china its own world
in the united states and there's this
gap of total cultural understanding like
we're it's not that
um
like we're not
competing superpowers they're almost
like doing their own thing
there's that that feeling and i think
that means there's a lack of
understanding of culture of people and
we need to kind of bridge that
understanding i mean you know the
language barrier but also cultural
understanding making movies
that's
uh that you
use both and explore both cultures and
all that kind of stuff to where like
it's okay to compete
you know like rocky where um
uh
rocky balboa fought the russian
uh fact you know historically inaccurate
because obviously the russians win but
you know we have to i'm just kidding as
a philly person i was of course rooting
for rocky but the the thing is those two
superpowers are in the movies china is
like its own
out their thing we need more rock rocky
seven
i do think there's a certain
inscrutability to the politics there and
an insularity to the politics such that
it's harder for westerners even if they
know even just to learn about it and
understand what's going on that i think
that's a problem and vice versa
um
so i think that's true but i at this
at the same time we could point to all
sorts of things on the other side of the
ledger like the massive amounts of
chinese immigration into the united
states and the massive number of people
who are now like how many so many more
americans business people politicians
understand so much more about china now
than they did 34 years ago because we're
so intertwined so so i don't know where
where it balances out i think it
balances out on better understanding
than ever before
but you're right there was like a big
gulf there
that we haven't totally bridged
yeah and like i said lots of
inter chinese in the united states
sexual intercourse no
and love and marriage and all that kind
of social social cohesion
you